it's hard to believe it's been nearly 7
years since we were first introduced to
the new era of the wild of Zelda games
and almost a full decade since it was
first teased to us along with breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom came a
bunch of bosses for link to face some of
which are completely new and others of
which are new appearances of old
monsters in the franchise and we've got
all of the stories in lore behind each
and every one of them nice and bundled
up and explained away in this video so
whether you've seen my boss L videos
before and need a refresher or this is
the first time you're seeing them at all
sit back relax and enjoy this One-Stop
shop of all of the lore behind every
modern Zelda boss oh and spoiler alert
obviously a Zelda game without bosses is
like a pizza with only cheese on it
which some people like but where's the
meat where's the olives where's the
pineapple Mama Mia to start let's cover
the Overworld bosses in the game which
admittedly count for like 107 of the4
total bosses in breath of the wild or a
whopping 94% the biggest number of
Overworld bosses comes from two types of
giant monsters the HX and the stone
Talis Hues are actually recurring bosses
in the zeld franchise you may recognize
them from their previous iterations in A
Link to the Past links Awakening or A
Link Between Worlds in every appearance
they're always giant Cyclops like
enemies although by far their biggest
appearance size-wise has got to be in
breath of the wild where they appear to
be oh at least 30 ft tall or so because
hexes are present in other games just
like boblins or moblins or Liz alos or
even stalos it can be assumed that they
Origins are similar to any monster found
across Hyrule which either means that
they're just a natural species of being
that just so happens to be evil or that
they were created by way of the malice
of demise which is a decently widely
believed Theory insinuating that all
monsters across the world of Hyrule or
at least the organic ones are made of
malice which originated from demise
should this be the case then hinoxes are
no different and have simply been
created by Calamity Ganon and just like
most of the other enemies throughout the
game their connection to ganon's fish
power according to the compendium is
what results in their different in
colors according to their individual
power levels a couple Hues are actually
dead and come back to life as the
skeletal versions called stal noxes
which is of course due to the influence
of ganon's power and most likely shares
an explanation with all stall enemies
spanning the entire franchise the bigger
question is why Ganon doesn't just make
all of his monsters immortal like the
stall monsters you'd think that would be
a pretty big brain move who knows maybe
his evil power can only go so far moving
on the stone Talis bosses are quite
literally living rocks that you know try
to commit murder upon seeing link
because they're made of solid rock
they're extremely durable and take very
little damage unless you attack a
certain spot and the spot appears to be
their exposed brain or maybe even heart
on their central body piece which
normally looks like an ore deposit and
is pretty much the only feasible way to
kill one of these Rocky dudes they also
seem to operate like a hub where really
their little brain deposit is the actual
stone Talis itself and everything else
just kind of sticks on or hovers around
forming arms and legs due to Magic this
enables them to mix and match other
Stone types into their body allowing
them to literally hurl their gigantic
Stone Arms weighing multiple tons
through the air in order to crush your
tiny human skull then just suck some
more rocks out of the ground to create a
new arm like nothing ever happened or
make their entire bodies out of molten
rock or even Frozen Rock now we could
also just say that ganon's power makes
the stone Talis monsters come to life
which is probably true either way but
there does appear to be some strange
things going on with them and patterns
that we can pick up on that would lead
us to believe that there's more to this
picture with regards to how they work
for instance Stone taluses appear to
grow and mature over time this is
evidenced by the little bitty baby stone
taluses called peets that you find
throughout the land followed by the
stone Talis Junior and stone Talis
senior bosses it could be that stone
taluses are really just little nuclei
that grow as minerals settle around them
leading to them growing or maturing over
time which is how rocks are formed in
real life so this explanation would be
fitting but the biggest question about
these Rock dudes is where did that
little nucleus come from is it a
creation of ganons because he was just
feeling our artistic one day when he saw
our Rock for a more thorough Theory
check out this one I did about the
possibility of stone Talis is actually
coming from outer space I'll link to it
below and be sure to bring your tin hat
with you with the hinoxes and stone
taluses out of the way let's move on to
the molduga this is the rarest kind of
recurring boss in the game and again
reanimates when ganon's power surges
under the light of a Blood Moon so again
it could be assumed that mouas are
Simply Creations of malice on the other
hand creatures heavily resembling
moldugas can be seen throughout the
franchise as well like the mold dorms
from Twilight Princess which also swim
through the sand or the mulgara boss
from the Wind Waker and yes I will be
doing a Wind Waker video soon so stay
tuned however I would like to present
one other possible explanation that ties
the malice Theory into the wildli of
breath of the wild and that would be
that moldugas could be malice corrupted
sand seals it would make sense given the
corruption that malice is known for and
the fact that mugas have horizontal tals
unlike all of the other wormlike mole
enemies spread throughout the franchise
but of course this is just my theory the
biggest molduga is the moldo King that
shows up in breath of the Wild's DLC but
to be honest that's probably just a
bigger sand seal moving on to the last
World boss in the game which the wiki
doesn't count as a boss but I absolutely
do enter the wonderful peaceloving
Lionel that's a joke these things are
allergic to peace lionels have once
again had other appearances in the
franchise first appearing in the first
game actually which means that the
centaur-like liony as a concept in Zelda
actually predates the bobblin which is
one of Zelda's most common enemies in my
opinion lionels have essentially the
exact same backstory Sloss explanations
as the hexes do they are also biological
monsters that could have either just
been abound in the land of Hyrule or
created purely out of malice one thing
that's notable about them though is
their intelligence which is rather high
for a monster their weapons are forged
from metal like the lizol foes they can
see through disguises and they equip
multiple different items like a bow and
arrow and sword and shield or spear or
large beat stick the fact that they do
Forge weapons and there are many of them
leads many fans to believe that there
could be camps or communities of Lionel
that survive together and share
resources which would only make sense
given that other enemies in the game do
the same thing we never come across a
linal camp in game but perhaps we'll see
some of these groups and tear of the
Kingdom as terrifying as that would be
with the world bosses out of the way
it's time to move on to the unique
bosses of the game aside from the final
boss Calamity Ganon and unfortunately
there are only two one of which is
locked behind DLC so really there's only
one in the base game yeah breath of the
wild definitely could have capitalized
on having more unique bosses but anyway
let's start with the one in the base
game the strong the Bur the one the only
Master Koga himself Top Banana of the
yiga clan the yiga clan as most fans
know are defectors of the Sha Clan and
as such are the same race of human
beings and feature the same white hair
and red eyes as proven by the ex yiga
man we meet in game Dorian the yiga clan
has sworn off their sibling shika Clan
and everything they stand for which
includes the hilan royal family and the
hilan deities because of this they
actually serve Ganon instead and are
both trying to hasten his resurrection
and scouring the land in search of the
hero link just in case he happens to
still be alive 100 years later this
command is said to have been given
directly from their leader and is so
ingrained in their brains that they
actually carry out their sworn Duty even
when their leader is taken out of the
picture Koga himself has been alive for
over 100 years according to the age of
Calamity and apparently is the deao
leader of the yiga and in spite of his
lazy napping nature is actually the
earner of the utmost respect from them
due to his Mastery of secret combat
techniques he claims that his techniques
come from his father's mother's father
which could possibly insinuate that his
bloodline has ruled the yiga clan for
several Generations since the secret
combat techniques that earn him his
respect didn't originate from him and
that's about all we know about Koga
anyway moving on to the next unique boss
in the game monk Maz kosia masz koshia
is one of the well over 100 chika monks
in the game present within the shrines
that were built over 10,000 years ago
the monks themselves appear to have
committed a process known as
sokushinbutsu which is the real life
Buddhist art of self-mummification that
almost 20 Japanese shingon monks
actually managed to do between the years
of 1081 and 1903 however even a
mummified human body can only take so
many Millennia and as such all of the
monks in breath of the wild dissolve
into dust after their shrines are
completed well all except for one masz
koshia is much more involved with link
than any of the other Shrine monks where
each of them designed their own
respective shrines and normally welcome
link and congratulate him upon
completing their shrines Mas kosia
actually orchestrates and guides link
telepathically through the entire
Champions ballot quest line which takes
place all over Hyrule once link finishes
the many many steps to finding and
completing the much larger final trial
Maz kosia actually proves that these
monks may have still been alive and that
their voices weren't just Echoes of the
past recordings but that they were
really talking to link and may have even
been able to not only move a little but
move a lot masz kosia actually stands up
and straight up fights link and what he
refers to as the final trial within the
final trial which is probably one of the
coolest moments in the game it's unknown
what masz kush's relationship was to the
other Shrine monks as in whether or not
he was their leader or something but he
definitely was the greatest of them and
I personally like believing that the
shrines and trials in general were all
his idea since he refers to his own as
the final trial a neat little piece of
gameplay in lore that connects the shika
and yiga together would be the fact that
you can drop a banana on the ground for
masz kosia and he will uh do this
similarly you can drop a banana on the
ground for a yiga soldier and they will
act the same now like I said before they
really are of the same Race So this
banana Obsession seems to run in the
family if you will Mas kosh's fighting
styles are also interesting and allude
to some in Universe lore as well such as
his ability to summon the extremely
similar spiky balls that Koga does
implying that koga's super secret combat
technique is actually a shika one and
that masz koshia might even be related
to Koga since the technique apparently
runs in koga's family plus koshia and
Koga do actually sound pretty similar
perhaps he even is koga's father's
mother's father I mean these Chik types
do tend to live a long time maybe the
bananas are the secret to long life
anyway koshia can also duplicate himself
which is the exact same move that impa
can pull off in age of Calamity once
again alluding to shika combat prowess
other than his mov at trials and
potential relation to Koga though there
isn't much else to talk about regarding
monk masz koshia so now we'll move on
and let his bones rest once and for all
the final boss SL bosses we're going to
cover in this video would be that of
Calamity Ganon himself I mean itself and
all of its goons for those who might be
unfamiliar Calamity Ganon is the latest
iteration of Ganon who originates from
Ganon Dorf on him in my aaring of time
and Twilight Princess and soon to be
Windwalker boss videos though it is said
that by the time of breath of the wild
Ganon had been defeated and resurrected
Time After Time After Time again so much
so that his eventual return is something
that can be relied upon prophetically
but why is he able to come back over and
over where did Calamity Ganon even come
from great question and the answer is in
my opinion from demise now buckle up
because I'm going to explain to you my
personal theory on the origins of
Calamity Ganon and Ganon in general
which could differ from your own you are
of course free to believe leave
whichever you want but check this out
dea's Essence is sealed within the
master sword this much is a fact proven
by the ending of Skyward Sword however
before he Fades away he promises that an
incarnation of his hatred will forever
follow the bloodline of H and the spirit
of the hero all the while laughing his
ass off and kind of having a jolly good
time ask yourself though what's so funny
about losing a battle to a teeny tiny
little insignificant human welp it's not
like he was able to perform some ritual
in order to bring this curse of his into
life and no offense but that's kind of
poor storytelling if he's a able to
literally curse the universe as we know
it by simply thinking it up in his brain
moments before literally being
eradicated from existence this franchise
is a big fan of rituals and grandor
happenings that precede major events or
changes in story so if demise who was so
cocky that he would win 20 minutes ago
gets his ass handed to him and is then
unable to perform a curse on halia then
why is he laughing well I'll tell you
what I think I think demise had already
cursed the world with his malice think
about it he was sealed away in the giant
imprisoned avocado for many years Years
Ago by halia herself yet monsters still
plagued the surface of early era Hyrule
and these monsters just so happened to
be created by malice so clearly demise
must have released his malice into the
world before he was ever imprisoned
possibly back in the age where he and
halia battled directly and you know what
calamity Ganon is made of malice in its
purest form the culmination of all of
demise' hatred Unleashed upon the
universe in order to be a Scourge upon
Hal's bloodline epitomized into the
Mindless formless monster known as
Calamity Ganon but I hear you wondering
aloud but Bandit how did Ganondorf turn
into Ganon if Calamity Ganon comes from
malice which is separate from Ganondorf
well I'll tell you it's because I
believe that Calamity Ganon and regular
ganet are two different monsters that's
right you heard me two different things
and for proof of this let's look at the
origin of Ganon canonically he was
created at this moment at the end of
Ocarina of Time When Ganondorf moments
from Death calls upon the power of the
Triforce of power to transform into a
hideous power hungry Pig Beast which is
then killed by L is never seen again but
Bandit I hear you wondering aloud once
more Ganon comes back in other games yes
yes he does but as different ganons each
time except for the Ganon in A Link to
the Past and onward in this timeline he
just Remains the Same walking on two
legs version of Ganon since the Fallen
timeline only happens of Ganon kills
link here at the end but in Twilight
Princess Ganondorf once again transforms
into a Ganon referred to as dark Beast
Ganon who is a four-legged version
created via the power of the Twilight
and is then killed by Lincoln midna
never to be seen again in Wind Waker
since ganador retained the Triforce of
power following his defeat at the hands
of the hero of time but since Ganon had
been killed previously in Ocarina of
Time he instead infuses a giant freaky
transforming puppet with his power and
calls it puppet Ganon now there are
other appearances of Ganon in the Fallen
timeline but I won't take the time to go
over each of them now my point is that
what if Ganon is the monster that
Ganondorf creates when infused with a
large external source of power be it the
Triforce the Twilight or malice see it's
my opinion that due to seeing
ganondorf's corpse spewing malice from
within in the tears of the Kingdom
trailers Calamity Ganon is the
culmination of demise' leftover malice
that has gotten a hold of Ganondorf and
used his body over and over and over
again over the countless Millennia to
create many different Calamity ganons
some of which even took different forms
and what's more is that perhaps the
malice appearing in tears of the Kingdom
right around the ganador corpse is more
tendr likee and thick and deeply red in
color because it's bonded with
ganondorf's blood which resulted in his
drained appearance now the other
versions of Calamity Ganon called the
blight ganons which each take on the
abilities and moves of the Champions
they were responsible for killing 100
years ago are simply extensions of
Calamity genon itself since it's just
made of malice anyway and we know that
malice can clearly split apart as much
as it wants to across Hyrule and can
even create other monsters given that it
has bodies to corrupt and therefore
create other ganin should it have a body
like ganondorfs that's powerful enough
to corrupt and wouldn't you know it we
can't find the Champions bodies anywhere
in the game and their blight ganons each
move just like like they do but for a
much deeper dive into what I'm
insinuating here check out my video that
I did on that exact topic linked
below a Zelda game without bosses is
like biscuits without gravy Jam or
butter my fellow Southerners will get
that one like yeah you might have a
super yummy biscuit that's all warm and
fluffy but without any toppings where's
the hearty flavor the Tangy fuess the
melty butter The Legend of Zelda tears
of the Kingdom fixed something that a
lot of fans had a problem with in its
predecessor and that is the addition of
new unique bosses that serve to flavor
up the biscuit that is the world of
Hyrule now before we dive head first
into the Waters of explanation we've got
to cover a disclaimer to check for rocks
because if okay I'm done with these
weird metaphors for now basically couple
disclaimers to get through some of the
bosses and tear of the kingdom are in
fact carryover bosses from breath of the
wild such as the stone taluses Hues or
lionels and as such will not be
retouched in this video since their
explanations carry over pretty
seamlessly if you swap anytime I mention
malice for glue Blom right off the bat
we're going to tackle explaining the
bosses that all have something in common
and that would be the majority of the
bosses in the game that appear to be
either creations of pure Gloom or Gloom
infused Wildlife or remains of organic
material such as the gibdos not unlike
the bosses that were created out of
malice from breath of the wild the
bosses that fit this criteria would
include the gleo kulgera Moria marbled
GMA the mckaro the boss bobblin the
queen gibdo and the Phantom ganons
obviously the one thing the vast major
majority of monsters from both breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom have
in common is ganon's malice or
ganondorf's Gloom respectively but that
doesn't mean that there aren't still
details to be uncovered about each of
these monsters boss mcoins for instance
were not present in breath of the wild
yet are present in tears of the Kingdom
implying heavily that the events of the
upheaval are what led directly to their
existence which is to say that linoln
Zelda waking Ganondorf up at the
beginning of the game and releasing the
full power of His Gloom into the world
is what directly led to the existence of
not only the bins but the boss boblins
which are literally just bigger variants
of boblins That Swing bigger weapons as
the result of being you know bigger and
bigger is better since they are bigger
better they're normally the leaders of
their little bobblin gangs and lead the
whole troop around in their little
patrols which is kind of cute and wield
the most powerful of the Boko weapons
and you know how in the last game
everyone was scared whenever they
encountered a liony well in this game
that feeling is still there but for the
new powerful three-headed dragons called
King goras I mean glyos which come in
four varieties flame Frost Thunder and
King which is a combination of all three
tons of fun these dragons are directly
said to have only appeared after the
upheaval which again proves that they
are creations of Gloom that were
released upon the world following
ganondorf's Reawakening interestingly
enough this is not the only time the gly
boss dragon has been seen in the series
actually a gly is an original enemy with
its first appearance being in the first
game The Legend of Zelda where it
appears three times as two three and
four-headed version of itself they've
appeared in some of the handheld Zelda
Titles since then but their terrifying
tears of the Kingdom appearance is the
first time we've seen the formidable
beasties on a Home console since the
beginning of the series and who knows
why Ganondorf decided to make them maybe
the original glys were also creations of
that gon meaning this is just a good old
Ganondorf original Monster design or
maybe he was just a big fan of the
original game who knows kg is an
interesting boss to encounter in the
game because not only is it a huge
flying ice monster that's powerful
enough to plunge an entire region into a
permanent BL lizard but it's also
remarkably similar to an earlier boss in
the franchise the molgera in both its
name and its design both monsters are
large flying Serpentine creatures that
freely manipulate and travel through not
only the air but the elements they are
bound to with kera's element being ice
and molger is being sand the other part
that's interesting about kulgera is its
first appearance being inside the
ominous wind temple high above the reto
village but that's another explanation
for the upcoming lore of the dungeons
video have I mentioned that you should
be subscribed anyway kera's similarity
to molgera extends to the fact that even
molgera was a creation of ganondorfs
back in the Wind Waker so once again
perhaps this monster design is either a
Ganondorf original or a literal
resurrection of the monster mulgara
although that's purely speculative
kulgera and most of the other dungeon
bosses in the game can all be
encountered in multiple different places
in the depths after being defeated in
their corresponding dungeons which means
there are multiples of each again
proving their existence as pure
creations of Gloom moving on the next
Gloom boss would be the queen gibdo
which is a terrifying combination of
giant flying insect and the literal
Undead now to my knowledge there has
never been a monster quite like this in
the series before we have faced giant
insects before and we've even faced
giant Undead before but never a giant
flying insect Undead that seems like
ground that shouldn't have been crossed
but hey here we are the queen gibdo
appears to Simply Be a giant super
mutated moth gibdo which similarly to
the queen also fly with moth wings and
can aggressively spit at link to hurt
him all of the gibo and tears of the
Kingdom the queen included share the
weakness to light that the Reds from
earlier games in the series also do
which heavily implies a connection
between the two types of enemies that
connection being the dark Unholy
reanimation of human corpses the queen
can also produce large amounts of sand
enough to cover the entire guto desert
region in a sand shroud whilst releasing
the reanimated moth and regular gibdos
into the area to hunt the living creepy
stuff the Tiny But Mighty mukar Rock
which was responsible for covering the
entire Zora region in a goopy sub called
sludge appears to really just be a Gloom
mutated octoroc which is quite blatantly
proven by the fact that it drops octo
balloons octar rooc eyeballs and even
octar Rock Tentacles when defeated in
the depths so that was pretty mucking
simple moving on though the next boss is
the marbled Rock roast I know the
substance is technically just called
gloom Rock but I want to call it marbled
Rock roast and marbled Rock roast is
literally responsible for the following
three bosses yunobo Moria and marbled
GMA and yes I do mean that yunobo from
breath of the wild yunobo was was
visited by the fake Princess Zelda that
was really just a phantom Ganon in
Disguise and given a strange mask to
wear that altered his personality and
made him feed marbled Rock roasts to the
citizens of gouon City leading to all of
them becoming Gloom fluenced as well
when he was under the influence he did
end up upgrading his wardrobe a bit and
becoming a mob boss though so I can't be
too mad at him plus he snaps out of it
once link beats the mask off of him the
Moria is an interesting boss because it
is clearly named to be a reference to
volvagia which is the legend AR fire
dragon that once lived within Death
Mountain and was defeated by the hero of
time wielding the mighty Megaton Hammer
Moria appears to literally be a living
rock monster though so there's not too
much to explain here without pure leaps
of speculation like if I were to say
that it's possible that Moria is
literally the reincarnated Spirit of
volvagia given rock form I mean its
design is pretty draconic and serves to
further solidify its references to the
dragon volvagia who has been long dead
at this point so I would say why
couldn't it be a possibility the the
final monster that marbled Rock roast is
responsible for creating would be the
marbled GMA a huge four-legged oneeyed
spider-like monster incased in rock that
can produce unlimited amounts of Gloom
Rock and right off the bat veteran fans
of the series will recognize the name
GMA from several appearances of the
other monsters and bosses all named the
same thing that makes several
appearances across the franchise always
appearing as a oneeyed arachnid type
monster and uh perhaps it would be more
accurate to say that the marbled GMA is
the one responsible for the marbled Rock
roast according to the compendium the
marbled GMA is the one that spread Gloom
rock across the entire Elden region
meaning Gloom rock is literally marbled
G's
secretions delicious just like the other
dungeons bosses marbled GMA has
callbacks to earlier bosses from the
franchise implying that either Ganondorf
keeps his designs or perhaps some
monsters reincarnate alongside the demon
king and the spirit of the hero now
there's a thought the final Gloom
creation boss to tackle before moving on
would be the Gloom spawns also known as
the Phantom ganons and strangely enough
I feel like their actual Phantom Ganon
appearance is less terrifying than their
Gloom spawn appearance especially when
they start shrieking at you and the sky
turns blood red now Phantom ganons have
been around in the franchise for some
time with the first appearance of the
iconic foe being in ocarine of time and
subsequently appearing in the Wind Waker
four Swords Adventures and breath of the
wild as the blight ganons in tears of
the Kingdom though this Ganondorf had
the bright idea of literally duplicating
himself since he's such a good fighter
and sending these duplicates out into
the world with Weaponry to seek link out
in order to you know make him not alive
anymore interestingly the compendium
states that Phantom ganons are made of
ganondorf's own flesh and blood and
since they are creations of Gloom this
would therefore logically imply that
Gloom can be described as the Flesh and
Blood Of The Demon King and this would
make sense given that the amount of the
goopy substance known as Gloom leaking
out of his body seems to directly
correlate with his dry dehydrated
appearance but more on that in the next
video Believe It or Not There were
actually some bosses and tear of the
Kingdom that were not created by
ganondorf's Gloom well four to be exact
the first would be the brand new wild
monster species introduced in the game
the froes these giant frog likee
beasties appear to be some sort of
evolution of a frog that also somehow
bonded with zonite which all foxes
including the little babies drop upon
defeat their Japanese name is deug Gama
which is literally a Corruption of the
word GMA which means frog they are
completely nocturnal and are shown to
hate the light actively attack any sort
of light Bloom that link places anywhere
and as such they only live deep down in
the Dark of The Depths which means their
history is likely tied to the history of
the depths itself which is tied to the
history of the zonai themselves but for
the time being they appear to simply be
natural Wildlife that can grow quite
massive and really likes to catch a
quick meal by opening their gaping
mouths and waiting for a little person
to fall in be careful spelunking next
and speaking of the zonai we have the
flux constructs which are well giant
zonite constructs creator out of
multiple giant Zoni blocks which move
around using a zonai force that looks
similar to ultrahand which is a Zoni
ability seriously though as a little
side note most things in tear of the
Kingdom that are mysterious can be
explained by just saying the Zone ey
it's possible they were created to
assist in workloads by perhaps
transporting mining efforts but that
seems rather unlikely to me since each
and every flux construct is located on a
circular Battlefield or a battlefield of
some sort with some literally being on
their own little Battlefield Island it
appears to be quite obvious that these
constructs were created purely for trial
by combat and if the theory that all Sky
Islands were raised into the skies above
for the purposes of preparing link to
face Ganondorf is to be believed then
therefore these constructs were created
literally for link just like the other
training constructs and constructs of
all kinds in all the shrines but on the
other hand if you believe the sky
islands may have been up there for a
while but obscured by the magical Cloud
barrier it is then possible that they
were created for other zonai Warriors to
practice combat with but that's neither
here nor there ultimately they are
combat zonai constructs that were
created for the purpose of training a
fighter and even have a very large weak
spot but speaking of which that leads me
to the next zonai construct boss the
seized construct which is faced as the
boss of the spirit Temple now this one
also has a pretty simple explanation see
ru's older sister monu was a tinkerer
and an inventor in fact she and Zelda
Were Somehow able to get the shika warp
functions working well before any shika
Construction were present in the world
based solely off of information derived
from the shica Slate I mean the perad so
yeah she's kind of an era defining Super
Genius she was also very interested in
researching the concept of bonding one's
spirit with Machinery which she actually
ended up doing by bonding herself within
the purad and eventually Awakening to
talk to link and get him to build a new
crafter construct from within the
construct Factory why she decided to not
talk to link before this point and maybe
brief him about some of the stuff that
went down ages ago who knows but either
way the seed construct boss is a Gloom
infected crafter construct that is
exactly like the one link assembles
under the instruction of minu its
possession by Gloom is extremely similar
to the way that the shik constructs
would be possessed by malice in breath
of the wild the final non-g Gloom
created boss in tears of the Kingdom
would be Master Koga Top Banana of the
yiga clan himself now I know he appeared
in breath of the wild and therefore has
an explanation in my breath of the wild
boss Lor video but he's a living
character who actually has some stuff
happened to him in between games that's
worth mentioning if you'll call upon
being bested by link and breath of the
wild he was pushed by himself down the
eiga hole which previously had left his
fate unanswered by now of course we know
that this hole is really just a Chasm
that leads down Into the Depths which
Koga survived falling into somehow
anyway once down in the depths he was
able to somehow contact his other yiga
clan members and begin moving the
operations down there with the new name
of the game being ultrahand zonite and
the zonite constructs koga's new plan
Anders of the Kingdom before being
beaten once again by link of course is
to build yet another crafter construct
in order to beat link and gain the
attention of the demon king who I'm
pretty sure doesn't even know that Koga
exists ouch his fate is once again left
up to our imagination since the last
thing we see of him is his muscular body
being blasted off by 1 million zonai
Rockets of his own creation but you know
somehow I'm sure he still survived you
may have noticed there's one boss left
in tears of the Kingdom to talk about
and that would be the one the only
Ganondorf dragmire also known as The
Demon King himself also known as the
demon dragon but you see there's
actually not much solid evence given to
us in the game that would enable us to
fully explain ganondorf's actions and
tears of the Kingdom which means it is
time for a theory so once again make
sure you're subscribed so you know when
part two comes
out a Zelda game without bosses is like
a vanilla milkshake like yeah there are
those who just like a good classic not
very exciting vanilla milkshake but on
the other hand people like me tend to
prefer chocolate
with whipped cream and caramel syrup
drizzled on top as I briefly mentioned
at the end of my last video ganondorf's
appearance in teers of the kingdom is
actually pretty shrouded in mystery more
so than I think a lot of fans were
expecting since this was the Grand
Return of the most iconic Zelda villain
that we waited oh 17 years or so to see
again I'm not criticizing though just
making the statement that because his
appearance here is less fleshed out than
his previous iterations we will be
theorizing and speculating about his
Origins and true motivations but I'm
getting ahead of myself first let's
cover what we do know about the demon
king from dialogue and cut scenes in
game long before the events of the game
transpire the kingdom of hyru was
founded by a Zoni named raru and a hen
named Sonia in its infancy the kingdom
of hyru had reached out to its
surrounding kingdoms for the purposes of
declaring peace and establishing
agreements and trades or whatever it is
that kingdoms do with one another this
is how Ganondorf the king of the
neighboring gudo tribe is canonically
introduced to the hen king and queen as
after several attempts to reach out out
to the gudo and being met with no
response ganador finally decides to make
an appearance and declare his intent to
submit to the rule of the hen royal
family however Ganondorf was in fact
hiding his true intentions we can see
from a previous cut scene that Ganondorf
had recently actually tried to overthrow
the kingdom of Hyrule by summoning an
entire swarm of the dangerous desert
dwelling molduga beasts which were
pretty easily defeated by ru's super
cool light beam after his master evil
plan blows up in his face Ganondorf
spots raru Sonia and Zelda's zonai
secret stones from like a mile away
using his own natural eyesight anyway he
then becomes rather obsessed with the
zonai and their secret Stones as we can
see from this dialogue in the false
Allegiance cut scene literally bringing
up the subject of the ancient zonai out
of nowhere and saying it's unfortunate
that there are only two left in the
world raru and his sister minu then he
just kind of stares at him menacingly
and leaves upon being dismissed sometime
later Ganondorf attempts to assassinate
Sonia and attempt to steal her zonai
Secret Stone by creating a fake Princess
Zelda and asking to see the queen in
private however the incredibly wise
Queen and Princess Duo see right through
this deceit and are able to stop the
Guta blade from reaching the queen using
Zelda's Newfound recall ability but once
the puppet princess disintegrates Into
Thin Air the queen and real Zelda are
distracted and Ganondorf uses this
opportune moment to eliminate Sonia in a
single strike from behind catching her
secret Stone as she falls lifelessly to
the ground I would also like to point
out that Ganondorf is not holding a
weapon of any kind when this happens
which doesn't really make a difference
but I just wanted to draw attention to
the fact that he literally punched a
person Dead with a single hit yikes
anyway with the secret Stone in hand all
hell breaks loose both in Hyrule and on
ganondorf's face yikes again once the
stone bonds with its new master it
transforms him from his mortal gudo form
into that of the immortal Demon King
also giving him the ability to produce
endless amounts of Gloom which is a
super powerful evil substance powerful
enough to create endless monsters
overpower Ru and even shatter the
legendary Master Sword it also makes him
look really cool before the demon king
is able to kill the other two Royal hen
members in front of him Zelda warps all
three away leaving the Demon King to
further enhance his new monster Army and
Lead an allout assault on the kingdom of
hyru and her allies including his own
country of the gudo this prompts Zelda
and raru to summon five additional
Heroes as the sages of Hyrule and
Empower them each with their own zonai
secret stones in an attempt to defeat
the demon king Zelda however realizes
that this all must have already happened
in her original future timeline since
Ganondorf ends up still being alive in
the future she then warns rahu that this
might not go their way and rahu responds
by saying that he's just going to do it
anyway and says that worst case scenario
that Knight named link will save the
world since Zelda had been hyping him up
this entire time which is actually
really cute anyway eventually they do
face The Demon King in a one versus
7even fight which he ends up winning
pretty easily rahu then decides to
sacrifice his own life by absorbing the
dark demon energy from ganor cleansing
it through his body and expelling it as
light which won't kill the Demon King
but will keep him in stasis for a really
really long time and just before
Ganondorf enters his long but temporary
Slumber raru declares boldly that link
the Knight wielding the blade of Evil's
Bane will arrive one day to kill him
once and for all to which Ganondorf
replies our battle will be legendary the
remaining followers of raru then built
the famous Hyrule castle at top the
ceiling chamber in order to keep the
seal on Ganondorf intact in a nice
airtight container but one day in the
future 100 years or so before the
present day a little event called the
Calamity happened and weakened Hyrule
Castle which led to ganondorf's power
beginning to grow once again and ru's
body beginning to disintegrate into
light as the Gloom overpowered him
eventually this left his body very
nearly used up by the Time Zelda and
Link stumble upon the Demon King's
corpse in the present day once they
enter the chamber ru's hand either
knowingly or conveniently falls off of
the body of Ganondorf leading to Zelda
picking up raru Secret Stone and the
resurrection of the Demon King the first
thing he does is attack the pair with an
enormous amount of Gloom which mummifies
Link's entire arm and shatters the
master sword ganador expresses the fact
that he's disappointed with link since
raru hyped him up so much and then lifts
the damaged hyru Castle up into the air
popping the cork on his seal completely
and enabling him to spread his groom and
enabling him to spread his Gloom into
the world once again as he falls deep
into a chasm in addition to his monsters
beginning to spread in greater and
stronger numbers across the land he also
releases manifestations of himself
called Phantom ganons to seek out link
and attempt to assassinate him with one
Phantom Ganon becoming another puppet
Zelda and traveling around messing
things up which link spends the majority
of his Adventure fixing Ganondorf does
have a neat moment addressing link
directly when the hero faces the puppet
Zelda in battle feeling that link was
lucky to have survived his attack
initially due to ru's hand but then
realizing that link actually is you know
kind of a badass he then attempts to do
quadruple the Gloom damage to link but
but Link's friends the new sages with
the powers of the handed down zonai
secret stones are able to brush aside
the Gloom like it was nothing Ganondorf
then plays them in MP4 video of what
he's going to do to the world when his
power comes back fully threatens them
then laughs and leaves and the next time
we see Ganondorf is when he's approached
by Link in their first and final
Conflict long story short ganador for
hydrates threatens link fights a bit
gets beaten transforms into the Demon
King threatens link again fights a bit
more and then gets beaten again at this
point Ganondorf is so unwilling to to
let link whim that he decides to do the
irreversible to consume his zonai secret
Stone and become a dragon of Limitless
evil demon dragon potential then he gets
beaten again but this time link stabs
the zonai secret Stone destroying it and
Ganondorf and practically setting off a
nuke in the process and thus ends the
life of the newest iteration of
Ganondorf dragmire but now let's try to
explain the beginning of his life the
motivations behind his actions and
hatred of the kingdom of hyu that are
lightly touched on in the game if at all
and really quick before we get to that I
just wanted to take a moment and mention
my book it's a Zelda book which I've
been given the amazing and humbling
opportunity to write a bit of it would
mean the world to me and the author if
you would check it out and maybe even
consider pre-ordering it since there
aren't that many Zelda books out on the
market it'll be coming out later this
year and I'll leave a link to it in the
description below anyway as I've said
multiple times so far there isn't much
to go off of regarding ganondorf's
intentions aside from evil man evil plan
because of this we'll have to look at
the details we are given with a
magnifying glass and deduce what we can
from there and I'd like to point out
that if any of these conclusions are
contrary to what you might believe
personally you are more than welcome to
think differently that's the beauty of
theorizing as a community that being
said though I think that what we're
going to talk about today might not only
explain ganondorf's intentions and
appearance in tears of the Kingdom but
also his other appearances across the
franchise as well as an ancient Garuda
legend that has otherwise remained
unexplained for over 25 years but first
things first one of the loudest hidden
details about gan's appearance in tears
of the Kingdom would be the the gudo
shown behind him and by that I mean
these two masked gudo women in
particular they make two appearances
one's here on a gudo Highland Mountain
and On's here in the Hyrule Throne Room
both times being the closest guto women
to appear right behind Ganondorf these
twin guto women wear sashes that read
Kum and kotake which for veterans of the
franchise should immediately sound
familiar this is not the first time
we've seen twin guto of the same names
linked closely to Ganondorf in fact in
Ocarina of Time which was the first
appearance of all three characters K and
kotake are powerful Garuda witches
referred to as ganondorf's surrogate
mothers they also have the ability to
fuse together and form the big witch
known as twin Roa we don't have any such
text to prove a similar Connection in
tears of the Kingdom but if you'll
notice their skin is also green unlike
any of the other Garuda but similar to
one in particular Ganondorf their shared
odd green skin would imply a blood
connection between them and only them
and is also a pattern shared by their
original Kina of time appearances this
connection makes sense but it's the time
placement of these cutscenes that makes
the theorizing a bit difficult to place
because see if these cut scenes truly do
take place at the beginning of the
kingdom of hyru according to its known
existence which would have taken place
sometime before arine of time then that
would explain the guto twins's youthful
appearance however the guto twins
included all have pointed ears in the
cutscenes which as the very astute fans
know is a physical feature of the modern
gudo not the original gudo from back
inoc of time which is proven to us
canonically by contrasting the
appearances of the old and new Garuda
women and reading this segment from
creating a champion which states quite
clearly that the ancient gudo had
rounded ears the theories given to
explain their modern pointed ears are
debatable but what's not debatable is
the fact that the original guto did not
look like tears of the kingdoms kotake
and Kum or any of the guto shown in the
cut scenes for that matter except for
Ganondorf himself who does have rounded
ears but more on that in a bit this
hurts the placement of Tears the the
Kingdom's founding of Hyrule being
before ocarine of time and instead
implies it is after and thanks to an
interview between famitsu and Zelda
series producer a anuma and tears of the
Kingdom director hiim Maru fujibayashi
that was made public recently this idea
actually seems more likely now since
Fuji bayashi directly states that tear
of the Kingdom's account of the founding
of Hyrule could very well be more of a
refounding of Hyrule stating that it's
possible that it was destroyed once
before and this is actually huge because
it means that tears of the Kingdom's
founding of Hyrule pass is probably
still more futuristic than anything
we've seen on the timeline since the
kingdom of hyu is still alive and active
at the end of all three branches well
except for the adult timeline within
which the kingdom was in fact destroyed
by a flood and new hyu was founded
somewhere else entirely leaving the
original Kingdom of Hyrule open for a
refounding which would make sense given
the sea salt we find all over the place
in the era of the wild since it would
have been flooded by an ocean but hey
this isn't a timeline Theory video I I
need a break from those I brought it up
though to make the point that it's
probable given Fuji bash's insight and
the pointed gudo ears in the cut scenes
that the founding of Hyrule shown here
actually takes place after the current
timeline within which Ganondorf and
kotake and Kum have all been slain
however there is one case on the
existing Zelda Timeline that showcases
an interesting appearance of twin Roa
and that would be their appearance in
the Oracle games these games do take
place in the downfall timeline which
according to most theories is a timeline
that splits off of Vine of time if that
Ganondorf is able to kill the hero of
time at the end of the game after
transforming into Ganon this would mean
though that twin Roa has been killed in
the downfall timeline this implies that
their presence after being killed in the
Oracle games is actually therefore a
Reincarnation of the witches with their
entire plan being to resurrect their
surrogate's son who is now Ganon which
would also mean that calling them an
incarnation of demise' hatred is valid
and therefore gives Credence to their
evil intentions and connections to the
rest of the lore of the franchise so
here's my theory for tears of the
kingdoms twin Roa and Ganondorf what if
twin Roa has once again reincarnated or
resurrected as they've been shown to be
able to do in the Oracle games and
furthermore what if Ganondorf as a whole
has always been a creation of twin Roa
think about it they're known as his
surrogate mothers but you know biology
and stuff does imply that he must have
had a father and one mother but that
doesn't make sense since he has two
mothers unless he was created instead of
born but that would mean his mothers
would have had to have been extremely
powerful which is to pull off something
like that oh wait that's exactly what
they are and if we think about
ganondorf's existence this way then not
only do multiple ganondorfs Sporting
Green skin across the franchise makes
sense but it also makes sense as to why
the female exclusive race of the Garuda
would randomly give birth to one male
king once every hundred years that could
just be the rate at which twin Roba can
create suitable male heirs each
programmed from their creation to
attempt to overthrow the kingdom of
Hyrule and since it's the same ritual
creating the same being known as
Ganondorf he would also sport the same
rounded ears if it's true this explains
so many things the ancient gudal legend
of one male Heir every hundred years the
multiple appearances of a Ganondorf
throughout the franchise and the
appearance of kotake and Kum and tears
of the Kingdom's Cuts scenes which is
otherwise completely random all it
requires is that one of demise' cursed
incarnations known as twin rova
reincarnates once again after the end of
the current timeline which is very easy
to believe but that's just my theory and
like I said you are free to believe this
way or not it's your prerogative I am as
always very interested in your thoughts
though so please feel free to leave a
comment below detailing what you think
even if it's just to say hi or that you
think I'm weird or something it's okay I
can take it maybe and please consider
leaving a like on this video If you
enjoyed it or at least my efforts into
making it and would like to put a smile
on my face and make sure you're
subscribe to the channel to get
notifications on tons of gaming lore
explained in bite-size easy to
understand pieces and it also helps grow
the channel so that would be much
appreciated huge thanks as always to my
Bandit crew who make my day every day
and are the reason this channel is still
alive that's all I've got for this one
so follow me on my socials to keep up to
date and I'll see you next time this is
Bandit signing out
[Music]
peace